petroleum jelly in the door frame every
six months a flooding defense trick
kerry has learnt the hard way
flooding
never even entered my head
the force of the water was already in my
house it was
maybe two foot in the house
and that was like everything was gone
all the christmas presents
so these are all new builds these are
all slightly built up now so these don't
get flooded fifteen hundred of kerry's
neighbours now rely on her to interpret
weather warnings but flood education she
says is vital for everyone at risk took
us eight months to get back to
kind of normality
and then you add other people saying i
still talk about the floods
the environment agency is warning that
1.5 million households could get caught
out like kerry
their survey of households in areas at
risk of flooding showed just 4 percent
thought there was a definite risk
61 percent thought there was no risk at
all
and a third had made no efforts to
prepare for potential flooding
the met office is warning that this
winter is likely to be wetter than
normal although those wet conditions
aren't due until around january and
february
the time for households to prepare is
now
the environment agency says it is ready
with 250 mobile pumps and 6 000 trained
staff across the country so they can
take action wherever it's needed
construction and repair of flood
defenses has continued throughout the
year as part of the record 5.2 billion
pound government investment to better
protect
336 000 properties
we're just encouraging those people who
are not aware that they're at risk to do
so because it'll help protect themselves
and property by having a flood plan
taking having a bag to take your medical
documents medical medicines insurance
documents away with you
last month parts of the country saw a
month's worth of rain in 24 hours the
environment agency says its action
helped protect over 3 000 properties but
that nearly 80 households were flooded
it says it's ready for the next three
months of potentially wet weather
but every household at risk will also
need to be prepared
to avoid disruption this winter
saudia chowdhury sky news in manchester